[拍手]
今日は皆さん大阪大学で理論物理やっている橋戻っています
質問ですが
皆さんは世界と自分が繋がってるっていうふうに感じた事ってあるでしょうか
どうですか
僕はねあるんですしかも結構でずっとつながっているようなねそういう感覚があるん
ですね
でこれでむっちゃ楽しいですそれを今日はみなさんにお伝えしたいと思ってきました
これ今週の御堂筋線の中吊広告です
上の一番上のとこ見てくださいよく読んでください
注目の最先端研究者橋本晃司教授買ったという形でね
ほんであり醜いからちょっと大きく拡大しましょうね
中国の最先端研究者橋本康二
中国ですよ俺っていうかね
でこの中吊広告満たしたねまあ僕のことを知らない方も知らんでしょう
最先端研究者でどんな人だろうと思うでしょうね
ほんで普通科学者とか研究者っていうのはあの一般の人のイメージっていうのがあるん
ですよ
例えばのテレビドラムとか色々ありますけど白衣を着ている
ね pc ともしくはあのスーツを着ている
えあの大学で講義しますからご教壇に立ってスーツでかっこいいねこうやっている
そういうイメージあります
けどね本当の最先端研究者っていうのはそんなんじゃなくてですね
あの困難です
これ僕の写真ですけど上からが t シャツランパン
3波
今日もまぁいつも通りの加工ですよこれは冬だから寒いからジーパン入りますけどね
最先端研究者というのはあまねくとは言わないけれどもこういう格好してる人多いと
思います
それはね世間とタブキャップがある
ってなんでね我々研究者はこんな格好してるのかということです
それはね答えは簡単でね実は研究者というのはもうずーっと
戦いの場に置かれているから
戦いをするのにスーツが入るか入らないんですん
むしろこういう自分に集中できるような格好した方がいい
それでこんな格好してるわけです
どんな戦いかという話を始めしましょう
これは僕のある日の1日ですね
朝起きるを戦う
こ
計算議論を
昼飯食います方でまたたか
ひどいときは昼飯食いながら戦ってる
今度番号が鳴ります風呂入ります
follow の中でも闘ってるだけやん
ほんで疲れ果てて寝るっていうね
で次の日の朝まだ戻るという感じです
そうな朝から晩までね戦ってるんです
もちろん科学者になるまで僕はそんなふうに戦う人生とは思ってませんでした
学部生の頃の僕の11見てましょうこんな感じ
もう10行を受けるの三軒屋けどもう眠いでもいいとか言ってね
入って本で4件はたもうアリアとか言ってねこれでゲーセンに行くわけですね
ずっとゲーセンで遊んで疲れた本よ僕が法によって
こんな感じでした
科学者になったらねこんな朝から晩まで戦っているなんて本当に思ってなかったです
でも実際はね
今戦っているんです
こういう格好でね
ほんでねその科学者が戦う理由それな人何をた下がっているのかというのね
科学者が社会と設定を持つのは実は一つだけで論文です
これ科学論文一例ですけどね
この紙切れ1枚これ紙一枚ですよ本当に
そのために科学者は戦って更新穴ここに注いでるわけです
この論文の上の方を見てみましょう
橋本なんとか書いてありますねこれはあの共同研究者です
この部分がどういう風にして戦いのせい出来上がって来たかってお話しますね
論文っていうのは初めにその科学のアイディア
着そそからスタートします
そしてそのアイデアを科学的に検証するそれは実験でもあるし計算でもあるし
いずれの分野で科学的な検証が行われます
その結果科学的に価値があると自分で判断する場合はローグを書くわけです
そして論文として社会に出て行くその社会に出て行くそこだけが科学者が社会と設定を
持っているところです
そこだけがね
共同研究者ここにありますね共同研究というのはチームワークやから
あのなんかどんな感じだって想像します京都謙虚
これ例えばねあのなんかテーブルとかを囲んでお茶でも飲みながらねこれはそういう風
にしたらいいんちゃうかなとかね
そんな風な和やかな雰囲気だと思うでしょ違います
これはね戦いなんです
共同研究者というのは的なんです
そういうつよりも1秒でも速くもっと面白いすごいアイデアを
そいつに投げかけるねもしくは1秒でも速く正確に計算してその計算結果を
そいつに見せつけるその欧州が共同研究なんです
強敵と書いて友と読むというね言葉があります
これ共同研究者のことなんです
共同研究者とそのようにこうねジャムを打った次はストレート闇だね
そういうふうな応酬が何ヶ月そして何年も続いて最終的に核の研究成果がこう
積みあがっていて論文な最後に
これが共同研究わけです
たまにはねあのものすごいを考えてたらね
夜中とかにあーこの愛でのすげーみたいなね
自分でね浸れる瞬間とかあるわけ
でそういう時はまあ気持ち的にはこんな感じで
桑庵みたいだね
こういうのがもう年に1回あるかないかですよ
これが来た時というのはもちろん非常に良いロングなります
でこの後論文を書きますもちろんアートかザート稼働住んでみたいなね
そういう非常に細かいところから共同研究者とやり合ってね
で論文というねまあ言うたら pdf ファイルですよ
数十キロバイトねっ
それを作るために数ヶ月数年費やしてそれを作り上げるわけです
今で発表どうするかというとですねあの我々理論化学の分野ではこんな風になってます
あるね web サーバーがあるんですね
そこにその pdf ファイルをアップロード数わけです
そしたらそれが全世界の研究者が見れる形になるというわけ
最後にねそのアップロードする瞬間ねこれのサブミットボタンというのがあるんです
けど
これ押すときにすごい手が震えるんですねこうね
むっちゃここに汗かいたりしてねー
そりゃそうですよねだって何ヶ月何年も心血注いでね
作った奴がもその価値っていうだけで
世の中に出ていくわけですからね
これでてがすべて何回も作品とできなかったことが多くあります
寒いとされたとしましょうこれ戦い終わりじゃないんですね
なぜかというとはどういう仕組みになっているかと言うとですねこのアーカイブ
システムというのはその前の日にサブミットされた論文等を集めて次の日の朝10時に
公開するというシステムだっています
次の日の朝10時でこういうホームページできる
このホームページを全世界の研究者を見ています
日本だと午前10時年アメリカだと呼ぶです
5全世界一斉に公開してるん
でこの日見てみましょうこの僕の狭い分野でも306編の論文が出てるんです
これ毎日ですよ
物理全体の分野だったらもう数百票になっています毎日です
ここでまた凄い戦いになるわけです
わかりますよね
例えばで僕がそのサブミットした次の日のこの朝だったらちょっと安心して見れますよ
俺のロング乗ってるわけだよね
違います
普段はですねこれを恐怖の心で毎朝毎朝見るわけです
なんでかというとねこれを見たときに
ひょっとしたら自分が今考えているアイデアと同じアイデアの論文が出てるかもしれん
そうそうそれマーケなわけです
でしょ
それめっちゃ怖いですよねだって自分が認めて何ヶ月ね検証してきたものが一瞬にして
他の人にもかっさらわれる理由
それめっちゃ強いわけです
そういう日は時々あります
僕も何回かありました
そんな時はも仕方なくもう共同研究者誘ってですね
もう生ビールですね
俺氏がない
を合わせましょうと
新しいことを考えましょうよ
そんな感じです
ばつまりちょっとまとめるとですね各社との社会の接点っていうのはあの論文です
この論文を仕上げるためにもんすごい戦いの毎日に科学者がいるっていうかこんな感じ
ですね
これつらいですよね
でも科学者毎日これやってやつ
ずっとやっていっ
こんなたぶん死ぬまで行っ
何が楽しいかという事ですよね
実はここに世界とつながるというそのキーワードがあります
ある朝の10時んですね僕の論文が公開されました
この論文の内容に基づいて自動的にこういうホームページがね
作られて
そのホームページが公開されます
その朝
あらゆる世界の科学者がですねそうホームページをクリックし始めるわけですね
でみます
そうしたらどうなるか
その研究者それを呼びますね
あ自分の考えと似てるもしくはこれすごいアイディアちゃう
それで僕にメールをくれます
後一周のうちに世界にそ伝わって
そのコミュニティの人が一瞬として自分の版自分に判断を下してそれでそのメールを
やってくるわけです
そのメールはもちろん音を巻くを間違っているそう言うね失敗
もしくはすごい安と3時激励
知ったそういうものが一瞬して世界中の科学者からやってくるんです
これね知ってる人じゃないですよ知らん人です
もちろん科学者全員知ってるわけないですからね
違う6やの人みたいにします
そういう人からばワート
連絡
そこで科学が自分と世界が繋げつながっているというね
すごい実感するわけです
そこからどうなるかというとその1 tone ディスカッションなります
つまりそれね向こうからね知らない向こうからいきなりね後ろから殴られみたいな感じ
ですよね
この街がてんちゃうんだよね
そしたらへーとか言ってくれてねー
それで欧州になるわけです
ところがそれがね新しい科学のタネになっていくわけですね
つまりその人が自分のアイディアを持って僕の間に上乗せしてくるわけ
そしてそこでまた科学が育っていくわけ
それを僕は離れて見ることができる
なる程度間隔が育ってきたそこで論が出るわけね
それを僕は見ます
そうするとまたその1コメントができるわけ
そしたら僕はなく慣れたところで殴り返してくるわけね
そしてそれがまた自分の所に来てまた自分のアイディアと融合するということが思い
ます
これは例えば成人した息子が就職して出て行って時々起業するみたよね
そんな感覚かもしれん
な鹿ですねあのカードが進むというのはそんな風に進んでいるわけですね
でもちろん自分のところに戻ってくるっていうようなそういうたぐいまれなアイデア
っていうのはなかなか人生に起こらないですよ
それは幸せなことです科学者の間ではそういうロングは美しい論文と言ってですね
他の論文と区別されます
は賞賛コメダの論文美しかったですね
言われるとトーキーとしてますね
むっちゃ嬉しい
僕人生で2回か3回ぐらいその美しいといわれたことあります
もうその夜は寝れませんでしたね
美しいロングというのは最大限の賛辞なんですね
そういう論文が世界中を巡って
で影響を与えています
そんな論合格ために科学者はこうやってね
散髪してね頭をボリボリ掻きながらね
5毎日戦いの日々を過ごしてるわけです
猫の高い戦い打てたらまあそういうなにが楽しいのっていう感じになるもちろん科学だ
から
真理の探究だけどもそれ以外楽しいことあの
人生楽しいんですかと
それはね実はあるんです
世界とつながっているということは実はむっちゃ楽しいことなんです
なんでかというと世界とつながっているということはその世界に実は自分が容易に個
入っていけるっていう
そういうことなんです立って一体化してますからね
世界に容易に入っていけるということはもうすごい楽しいことなんです
つまり科学というのは
世界の知らぬところでですね全く同じ問題を
ようにすごい深く考えている人たちがいるんですね
その一言は知らないけども科学のこういうコミュニケーションやり方によっていきのに
つながることがあるんですね
そういう人たちとと自分とはなんというか凄い凄い深い同法意識みたいなのがあって
お互いのその深いところにいきなり入っていけるみたいな
そういう感覚が存在しています
同市のエピソードがいくつかありました
例えばこの入りし虹のにーちゃんですね
僕ある研究会でこのイギリス人の人に会ってその後いろんなディスカッションして本音
何本か一緒に論文書いたんですね
であるとき彼の研究所北訪ねている時にあの一緒に酒飲みに行って
宗谷この人を
何歳かも聞いたことなかったなと思って聞いてみたんですよね
そしたらねお題としあっていいわけですよ
このああ面白いこともあるもんやな思って同い年だったちょっと誕生日聞きたくなる
じゃないですか
誕生日聞いたんですよ誕生日同じだったんですよ
びっくりしますよねー
だってねそんなことも知らんとね何でも一緒に共同研究してですよ
この実は同じ日に
世界の裏側で生まれてたみたいだね
すごいでしょ
これねやっぱりその普通はその年齢とか
国籍とかそういうのがまずあって人と親しくなるんですけど
科学者の間はそうじゃないということですねお互いに深いことを考えていたそういう
間柄というのはそれを超えてたっていう
それ方向驚きました
このおっさんね
この人はロシア子です
ある時ねまああの僕が私がメールかいたんですね彼のローブわからないから
ちょっとここを教えてくれって言って
それでディスカッションだったんです
この人知らんねんけどディスカッション続いたですね
ほんで最終的にはそのディスカッションの結果一緒に論文を書くことだと
2ヶ月れたってね何百ツボ rom あのメールやりとしていっ
本音論文格段になってこのさんなんかどういう顔したのかなと思ってホームページ見て
みたらですね
この写真があったんですね結構年配方はとか思ってない
ホンデロームがきました
その後数ヶ月ぐらいして
この人から連絡また来てあの日本の研究会に行くんやと
だから会おうという話で僕もその研究会に行くことにしたんですよ
で当日ね会場に入ったらこの写真そっくりの人がですね
会場の向こうのほうに言うわけですよこれ
音源すごい大男なんですよもーちゃ目立つんですよこの顔で
本殿は一やと思ってそしたら向こうもね僕のホームページで写真が載ってるから
僕のことがわかったみたいであーそこにうよみたいな感じで品でバーって走り寄って来
てね
ガーって強く抱擁してね方をバンバンバンバンただけあって公っていう
そんなことあります
これねもう一幸せな瞬間でしたねだってこの人あったことも見たことを喋ったことも
ない人だったんでしょ
でも一緒に論文を書いたんです
それでねこうだけあった瞬間で
これねホーマー世界を感じましたね
続けて楽しかったです
こんなふうに僕はいろんな人どう
あってですね
共同研究者たくさん作ってきました
みんな違う国の人ですねとし持ちが全然違う人です
けどねなんか繋がってます今でもつながったんですん
今この瞬間もこいつらはねぇ
動い研究してるんですよ
でいつかいきなり頭殴られるかもしれなわけですね
そうもうとずっとつながってんですよね
これすごい楽しいです
皆さんも
多分皆さんの環境で世界とつながる瞬間というのがあると思います
それを是非見つけて
楽しんでほしいと思います
以上ですありがとうございました
[拍手]